you can't function as a state without
laws and laws are designed to protect as
part of that but law is about protecting
people right it Brit Brit it's designed
to protect people being exploited that's
a whole visible function of what the
state should do the state's job is to
make society more fair more open more
meritocratic and states that make that
work have been prosperous so the young
lampur in China for example in 1400 he
said the best gift my father gave me was
40 years where nothing happened
peace and stability are massively
underrated you know as Hegel says the
pages of peace in history books are the
are the ones with no words on because we
love war we love revolution we love
change we love apocalyptic views we love
drama and we love crisis and actually
most normal people would say in my home
environment I don't any crisis at all I
will settle for boredom and a quiet
Friday night any day of the week
I'll be your mother loud to get quite
listened and and do we like war here
yeah empirically it's hard to say that
we don't I mean you know as I was and
listening the conversation in terms of
certainly what the US has done and I
personally think that Iraq the decision
on Iraq was a disaster and you may
recall that we were going to light the
flame of democracy I think and
definitions of terms are really
important and one of my learnings in
Iraq in Afghanistan and in other places
the the flame of democracy gets lit
initially if you have some semblance of
a rule of a rule of law if you if you
made me prioritize impacting a country
it would be first and foremost to put in
a rule of law from which an awful lot of
other things would grow which was the
exact opposite of what we did both in
Iraq and Afghanistan that's where I may
I may be biased but that's where I think
Europe is so important I think a world
trumpchi world it will be a problem well
with all respect for the United States
or China look to country that I know
relatively well that I visit because
Europe we are really committed probably
because of our experience of the
terrible Wars two world wars in fact
start as civil European Wars we should
not forget that most awful events of
mankind history were here in Europe and
more development part of Europe namely
Germany so that's where it started the
most probably the most tragic event of
mankind Shoah happen here in Europe so
this show of Europe is the issue of wars
except the last 60 years after the
European community was created where you
had no war in European Community
Territory philosophical the question is
what we considered a real important
value is it the state is it the party
did an ideology
is it a class or is it a human being
that's fine
some people call it individualism but I
I prefer to call it humanism or
personalism so the question is if you
think that our country we love our
countries I think most of us I mean I
love my country we are patriotic my
country is almost 900 years of existence
Portugal so I love my country but I
think it is not in contradiction to be
citizen of Europe and also why not to
say citizens of the world by the way
that's why I remember Prime Minister
have written recently that against the
tradition of Cosmopolitan's said that
citizens of the world are citizens of
nowhere I think we can be patriotic and
be citizens of the world and care about
human life and so and to last mankind
but I think it was Dostoyevsky there is
a personage there that says my father
loved mankind in general but he hated
every individual in particular that's
not the question is to a mankind is not
an abstract concept like the party the
class the nation-state mankind means
every man every woman every child and
this is why the focus philosophically
has to be on the person human being
that's right freedom is so important and
I believe that with all its
imperfections this free world is more
able than other parts of the world to
respond humanism
I'm not European but we are impacted by
everybody by by China by America by
Europe and by their policies in
Afghanistan as I said that we are in 41
years of war everybody is involved but
no one including us as an Afghan we are
not learning from history that is one of
the problem what has happened of course
in 1979 and 78 when the coup d'etat and
then the Russian invasion the European
in the American in the Arab countries
they choose the most conservative group
of people and they train them as a
fundamentalist Islamists to defeat USSR
on that time
when you USSR is collapsed then they
left Afghanistan they left us on our own
with poverty with really a destroyed
country and there must happen we had
Taliban and then with your hidden
government and now we have everybody so
I think what is what is really important
and I insist that our policies
everywhere that democracy liberalism and
everything should be based on human
rights and respect for human dignity we
do not do that one story you might tell
here is that the if you want freedom if
you want democracy you have to build it
yourself I think there's a there's a
pathos to these stories about
Afghanistan to Syria to it but also to
the Balkans where I was very much
involved and the external interventions
have been almost uniformly negative and
with some exceptions I don't want to get
I mean it's clear that Dayton help to
keep the Balkan war from going on but
but I come out of this thinking that the
stories you actually in the post 89
world you want to you want to look at
our place like Ghana as a country that
goes down has a very bad period of
authoritarian rule very corrupt
kleptocratic rule and it's now had three
or four successive free and fair
elections Ghana's doing it itself and I
I do I take that lesson being an
optimistic one if you want freedom if
you want democracy you got to do it
you've got to do it yourself outsiders
can help we can help a little bit at the
margins but unless there's a
constituency at home that is willing to
go all the way it can't happen
let me say a few sentences the main
force in any country is the mayor the
people of that country but the
international community can facilitate
and empower that people to promote
democracy that cannot be done through
bombs it should be done through
education another basic social services
in entry
in building empowerment empowering the
people of that country
you